prince harry is back in the uk for a
very special occasion
a source tells et the 36 year old royal
has safely arrived in his home country
for the unveiling of the statue of his
late mother princess diana
well of course this event in july is is
much anticipated
the unveiling of the diamond statue is
going to be an
important date it's firmly cemented in
both of the brothers calendars
harry and his brother prince william are
set to attend a small event to mark the
unveiling of a statue they commissioned
of their mother in the sunken garden at
kensington palace on july
1 a day which would have been diana's
60th birthday
i think everyone is hoping that we will
see the brothers
shoulder by shoulder to unveil that
statue in memory of their mother diana
always said to them
always stay close don't ever fall out
she would be devastated that that is
what's happened
and she would be wanting them to feed
her together for that unveiling of the
statue in her honor
a source tells et harry is now at
frogmore cottage
the windsor residence where he and his
wife meghan markle lived before stepping
away from their royal roles
the source adds prince harry will land
in the uk and
isolate for five days before taking a
covet test
affirming that he is negative before the
events of the day
a source also previously told et that
megan will not attend the unveiling of
the statue
seeing as she just gave birth to their
daughter lillabet diana
earlier this month meanwhile royal
expert katie nicholl told et in april
that while harry and william still have
a long way to go when it comes to
repairing their relationship
the unveiling of the statue of their
late mother is a significant event
things were not going to be resolved in
in one or two family meetings so while
this has been an important
step i think there's still quite a way
to go
the idea that harry's suddenly going to
come around to william's way of thinking
and vice versa
i think is is a way off i think there do
need to be
more conversations there's clearly still
a lot of hurt
a lot of resentment and a degree of
mistrust
i think on both parts harry was last in
the uk
in april to attend the funeral of his
grandfather prince philip
at the windsor castle ceremony he was
seen with other members of the royal
family
including prince charles his brother
william and duchess kate
for the first time since he and megan
stepped away from their formal roles in
the monarchy
so it's early days but i think the hope
is that come july when we are hoping to
see the brothers
stand once again shoulder by shoulder to
unveil
the statue in memory of their mother
that the relationship will be
stronger and in a better place